in these days of the two movement what
Jim Carrey just said to an interviewer
has plenty of people scratching their
heads he said what Jim Carrey is taking
heat today for comments he made to a
reporter while promoting his new movie
Sonic the Hedgehog's
oh you've done in your career and in
your life is there anything still left
on your bucket list just you so
apparently people saw this comment and
they went crazy they're like I can't
believe Jim said this it's absolutely
unacceptable they felt it was very
inappropriate and I thought it was
interesting so I went to go watch the
full clip just to you it's all done now
just own it that's the whole clip the
same way you brought attention to that
little part of what he said you have to
listen to everything and bring attention
to everything and put back that thing
into context what did he say
you're on my bucket and then he
proceeded that's it it's all done now
that means he did the bucket list
did he write there and then no therefore
he was obviously talking about the
interview
you're on my bucket list you interviewed
me it was a nice interview it was fun we
are done now because we just did that
and it's wonderful that's it but say it
making that little portion fits your
narrative Wow whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa
can we focus here levar can I switch
gears with you for cuz I have a question
yes where's dears with me anytime
yeah it's the same thing okay people
stop being lazy doing that is extremely
lazy but dangerous because you are
what's actually ruining someone's life
because you're being lazy
what are we also being lazy what if
we're just taking a couple of Twitter
comments that looks like a real thing
and we're blowing out of proportion I'm
pretty sure that 95% or 99% of people
who would see this clip would probably
feel the same way as us so is our
outraised really justified like you
getting loud
amen it just may be a minority of people
if it's a minority of people while
reporting something on a minority of
people that is outrage and making it an
outrage because if either a lot of
people are outraged or the media making
something out of a thing that is not a
Selenia it's the media because nobody's
talking about this other than a couple
people on Twitter be trying to do this
thing it's manufactured outreach the
machine how unreasonable these things
are most sensible people and I feel like
most people when it comes to a lot of
stuff are sensible I'm just wondering
are we freaking out about stuff that's
random here's the flipside it's like
what happened to levar ball when he was
on ESPN and then he got banned from
their network because of that comment
same vein it's like if the machine is
just testing things okay we did this to
levar can we do this to Jim know people
really love Jim so we can't do that -
sure I think can we do that to that
person okay that no that didn't work oh
and it works because now we pick up the
media story and then we cover it on
YouTube channel you know but you know my
stance is still the same if you got a
job you got to protect you can't be
joking with people all really nearly
like it's cool especially for a woman's
involved at work don't play that game
don't play the game
you know I'll give you another example
we know you have the basketball looks
but show us your best looks for the
camera here let us see a little flirty
fun a little flirty fun add good oh oh
that's real flirty
I like his icon dad and pouty I never be
sad and pouty what you said in there oh
that was cute what was it my DM I just
wanna see
I can't tell you what she says okay
let's hear them she's she's a Madea
oh my hair Danna no she says she says
even though Spanish you know I like that
chocolate Roxy got she got we be banned
from 106 & Park
she got this rapper banned from 106 in
part because he flirted with her back
stinkin my whole point being is that
she's like one set of standards for
Scheck one set of standards for him oh
he gets banned he does it my whole point
being is that it's just random you don't
know what's acceptable and this is why
I'm telling people I'm like don't joke
around with ladies at work especially
not with this tone Shaq is fortunate not
only because he's a giant mobile but
because she didn't want to make it a
weird thing but she could have easily
made it a weird thing okay yes this was
excessive it was I gotta admit it was
and it could have been a thing but maybe
like they got a relationship that we
don't know about and we didn't
understand your point you don't know for
sure for sure you cannot know for sure
and whenever you know we did that video
about you know 65% of men or not they've
not willing they don't feel comfortable
with women or car we're joking around
this is why it makes sense you know all
these stars that have you know girls
going their hoteling [ __ ] like that
right I wouldn't do that being like if
it's a single I wouldn't do that if I
wasn't filming cuz cuz you don't know
cuz you don't know you don't know so I'm
gonna play a little tip mememolly got
mad at [ __ ] on the floor levar can I
switch gears with you for cuz I have a
question yes where's dears with me
anytime
let's then go get there what you just
wanna take a step toward us a line okay
that's what you do in the ball step come
on Bobby
[Laughter]
[Music]
Changez
would you play game put your money on a
game that the rule changes starting with
that it's like I wouldn't play a game
that could cost me my career if there's
no benefit to winning the benefit to
winning and this is I make people laugh
if I lose I lose my career does that
sound like good stakes to you I'm not
playing call of duty if my real life in
real life is on the line okay bro you
play that game but every time you get
shot I see what happened
if I win you get this point yeah
standards are ever-changing so stop
joking with these ladies at the
workplace because even if you have to
pierce intentions they'll cut that
without context
they'll reprimand you they'll tell you
what you're doing is unacceptable
meanwhile women can get away with on
camera in terms of flirting with people
and nobody says oh yeah thank you thank
you now a lot has to do with luck to
something you're a great guy and you're
so handsome okay come on TV but I know
that they're there so you know how do
you think uh I am saying handsome oh
thank you
tell me more yeah really Olivia you guys
look hot guys so men understand even if
it's not fair these are the rules of
society play by them and be smart focus
on your bank you want a joke you do that
after hours not one ladies around and
I'm being dead ass serious about that
I'm gonna write that told that by my
sergeants in the military don't
fraternize and don't mess with there's a
reason for that and even there the
reason even in the army if because even
in the army they cannot back you up if
something happened and it is known that
you were guys when you guys in fact
you're in the zone that you're not
redeemable you're in no-man's land
it's unfortunate but that's what we had
because I to save yourself because it
makes it seem like women have no agency
like they have no power and no
responsibility and that they're too weak
to make any decisions
selves and I'm like you're also mocking
them
[Music]
does that work no and I'll tell her once
you go Shaq you never go back
Mita papi
let's tell the truth of what the DM say
all right I told you the heads up hey
I'm gonna be interviewing you my friend
educated so make me look good she didn't
tell me
surprise maybe so you owe me a date for
that oh you are they tell you I have a
Italian food beach so I have to pay oh
oh well if I'm taking you out on a date
then that means that I have to pay we
are in a steady relationship here this
is what she does me in my damn every day
okay how do not you please don't let
this man please try to make just have my
damn please oh my gosh yes yes he keeps
looking at me no I
yeah you keep looking at a little bit of
time with you right now
diesel so let's get to it right now
they're real soldier first thing you do
when you wake up first thing I do when I
wake up I say hey you alright
[Laughter]
I'm just playing America I've always
been a fan of Rajesh invasions very
talented